[Music]
laney is with us
laney is in what in the world did i do
there
hello there's laney hey laney welcome to
the ramsey show how can ken and i
hi help hi ken bear with me i have a lot
of moving pieces
um i'm an occupational therapist i work
in the hospital i also have a part-time
job and outpatient
i'm on baby step two i'm getting married
in
august and i'm just very burned out
on the hospital i'm living in asheville
my lease ends in november and the plan
was
was for my fiance to get a job first and
i kind of go from there because my job's
more flexible
um but i got anxious found a job
got offered the job and it's going to be
an 8 000
pay raise i'm just now i'm having second
thoughts on am i cornering my fiance
into
a place or should i where is the job
and where's the driver from greenville
south carolina okay so you would be
moving
and your your lease is up in november
and you're getting married to win again
august august okay and so had you guys
already decided on greenville south
carolina or this is where the job has
come up and now
he's got to decide or you have to decide
if that's where we want to go help me
understand
this is where the job came up so we have
not decided on a location
at all okay so if you're having second
thoughts what are his thoughts i'm sure
i'm assuming since you
mentioned him and cornering him have you
guys discussed this and what's his take
yeah um he he
isn't super decisive about it he likes
the area
but he does feel like
he wishes that he could find a job first
because
i could essentially go anywhere where
his it might be harder for him to find a
job
okay so you called us which way were you
leaning at the start of this call
oh i'm really really conflicted i
i'm really worried that i am
making a rash decision like to jump on
this job because i'm so burned out at
the hospital
okay and this job would start in
september so it's kind of like
a really quick easy out for me yeah i i
think you have to listen to that
uh here but i want to dive in here tell
me about the parts
that are causing you to feel burned out
and another way of asking this is what
would you remove if you had a magic wand
what would you pull away from what
you're doing right now that's sucking
your soul
out well so the biggest piece
is the salary is not
what i expected when i got the student
loans that i did
okay for an occupational therapist okay
if i'm working
that doesn't cause you to burn out
that's not work related that's emotion
attached to the reality that a lot of
people are facing when they get these
expensive degrees that they take loans
out and they go wait a second i thought
i was going to make more
i'm asking you do is there type is there
types of things you're doing that are
burning you out or is it just the
emotional
running to run right from this
particular hospital why why
what's sucking the life um so
it has been so many staff
cuts we're super we've been super
overworked
okay so you're overwhelmed which is
which i've written about this
i've got an article on this at
kencoleman.com it's one of the five
causes of what i call build up on the
heart
see burnout is the symptom if i go to
the doctor
today laney with a knee uh with knee
pain
i'm not going i've got knee pain i want
to know what's causing the pain
and and so being overwhelmed drinking
from a fire hydrant is
is what you're identifying here so let
me simplify this if we removed
all of the stuff that's causing all this
the stress
and just feeling overwhelmed and i put
you in a different place doing
occupational therapy would you be
happy in your work yeah i think so
i i am made to be an occupational
therapist
all right hold on pause that's huge
that's
what you have to realize you were made
to be an occupational therapist so we
are doing
the right thing in the wrong place we
have a little quiz
she knows that she's wanting to leave i
know but no dad gum inside coleman
she already told you that no but but she
needs to hear that because she was gonna
take another job just as an occupational
therapist
no she was gonna take it she was gonna
she was rushing into something as
opposed to saying
i need to stay in occupational therapy
she was she was going to
stay in occupational therapy yeah so the
other job is home health
it's not occupational therapy it's still
it's an occupational therapist
i thought you were staying you're
staying in the career but i thought i
heard her say it was a little bit
different than what she's doing now
okay misunderstand that let me back up a
second on something that's bothering me
in this whole thing
when are you getting married again
august
okay this is this is july
so when is it your fiance is going to go
get a freaking job
my thoughts exactly yeah i think he
needs to get off
painter get off the ladder here yeah
but you should not take the job in
greenville i don't think that's good for
the
relationship no i think but i think he's
got about 30 days
or no no whining like by the time you
get married he should have his job lined
up in the city
and then you go over there and get you
an occupational therapy job in that city
and you're still going to be in there by
september yes
and the point but him sitting around on
his butt till christmas not figuring
this out is not one of the options on
the table
right you could tell him i said that
or are you waiting on him like why do
you have to why does he have to go
you're not forcing him he does need to
get his button gear
but here's the point i'm trying to make
laney dave's having fun
with me i get it here's the point you're
not burned out from being an
occupational therapist
you're just burned out in the current
environment don't mistake that that's
all
stay with occupational therapy yeah
you're doing the right thing but
get out of that environment i agree and
i'm i'm with you on this laney i think
you can land that pretty easily
and you just have to be selective about
the environment wherever he wants but
he loses his option on cities
if he doesn't take the option by the
wedding
okay do you think i'd give him 30 days
he gets to
he gets until then to choose cities and
choose his little career thing
otherwise he'd be following you
yeah yeah and i don't want that i
i want him to grow in his career i
yeah i do too but that means he has to
actually go do it he has to get on the
ladder before he can climb
yeah what's he do what's his what's his
he's a supervisor in commercial
landscaping
well you can do that anywhere yeah i've
never heard of a supervisor in
landscaping deciding which city he wants
to go to i mean you guys collectively
say that this is where we want to live
we he can go do that anywhere as well
and you can go do occupational therapy
anywhere so
let's let's have a meeting tomorrow
night decide where we want to live
and then let's go get a couple jobs
there before the wedding yeah and then
you can quit your job and you'll be out
of that hospital by september
and you go to occupational therapy and
he goes dude goes and does commercial
landscaping
i mean any major metro area has got
commercial landscaping believe me
anybody's got office buildings and
apartments and so forth that's just
that's the deal
um so i mean there's 73 000 of them
within a two mile radius of this place
they're over here every day bothering us
so um
i know that you know it's just possible
right i mean can you yeah they want to
get this job right
this building yeah there's a lot of
landscaping to do around here
yeah so you're telling me you're not a
fan of the leaf blower right outside of
the conference rooms
is that what i'm hearing i don't know it
was like a thing at the old office every
time we would start a meeting
some guy would go out with a leaf blower
about the time we're in there
full on staff yeah right in the middle
of the meeting so yeah the great news is
you can land
both of these jobs anywhere you guys
want to do laney this is about you all
getting aligned on your timing
and your motivation and ambition and
both of you being on the same page
you're more driven to get out of that
hospital and he's not driven enough
i'm kicking him in the butt in this call
because he's leaving you
on hold and you on hold is driving you
bananas and you're screaming burn out
burn out burnout yeah
and there's really no burnout cause
you're gone by september
you can survive until september i
promise yeah
so you got this kid congratulations on
your marriage it's gonna be awesome
you're gonna have a great new city
picked out by the end of the week
awesome it's gonna be incredible